oh no i almost look a little scared
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until dawn
so i'm actually back from pax right now
and i don't know if i'm on a time limit
right now because
there is one uh decision hang on i gotta
okay let me get a little calm here
because this episode's starting up a
little bit
too insanely so
i'm back from pax i've read the comments
not a lot of them but i've read the
comments in the general sentiment is
that
people kind of agree with me that josh
is a little bit
shady and i'm pretty sure i have a
feeling just from all my experience of
being a horror gamer that josh is not
being totally honest but i don't know
why he would put himself in a situation
where he would be
split in half by a moving saw so with
that being said
i'm gonna save ashley
just because i scout my suspicions
oh guys oh my god oh god
i died
oh no
[Music]
no chosen oh good oh i don't know if
that's
oh god
why would you do this
know
why would he be okay why would anything
that you
just didn't be okay
[Laughter]
got to go okay
this game's not not very nice this game
is the anti-nice this game's the
opposite of nice
chris oh hey how's it going guys
oh hey how's it going oh good to see you
you having a fun date arguing are you
okay
chris what happened you're uh josh what
dude
you said no i'm right in front of us man
what are you talking about
maniac oh my god we gotta get out of
here i don't understand what happened
there's a maniac
it was there was a song it was either
him or ash
go right through my head spill it out
[ __ ] it everywhere
what oh my god chris why because i
i killed him i killed him
it was my fault no no this is insane we
need to go get some help
we're gonna figure this out matt we need
to go get help now
and we should look for the others mike
and jess are off 69
each other and who knows where sam is i
think she's in the lodge fine
you're right get everyone else together
but if there's a maniac running around i
think we need to get some help too
yeah but what about why are we still
talking about this let's go
okay
we're just going to waddle off over this
way oh man
this is this is so bizarre not because
of what's happening now but because of
the way the people are reacting to it
hello hi how are you i'm good
oh gross
you're so creepy man you're so creepy
but i love it i love you
you're so creepy
hello again hello things are getting
pretty tense up there
only a little bit tonight
no it's going
fine thank you it's going fine
and you think that these poor people are
getting what they deserve
i don't know what they deserve they just
wanted to have sex
oh is that so wrong what do you want
[Music]
i'm trying to help you
man you understand that it's not good
for you
it's not good for anyone anyone
and i can't say that you're showing much
loyalty in the way you're playing
what's the mystery here what am i
missing what is happening here that i
need to know about you need to give me
more information man because you're
holding back some key
info here the appointment didn't even
end you can't sulk off after
do you intend to continue
with this
you're freaking me out man you're
freaking me out you're freaking me out
man
i am real that's a good question
i thought that shiny was an apostrophe i
just
you're pretty real to me hey i believe
that you're real because you're a
shining part of the problem comes down
to this
uh-huh can you really tell the
difference anymore
hmm excellent question
i doubt it
oh i feel like the entirety of this game
is intended to be in the uncanny valley
but then who am i
who the hell am i okay all right we're
doing this whole wrap up again
i well i did just come back from pack so
bye jess sanatorium on the mountain
could he be hiding there
yes the old sanatorium ah
but of course now i still don't know who
i am
or not i am i'm talking in the
psychiatrist here i don't know who that
is that is me
so if i had oh no
looks like a war zone why aren't you
gonna go back for jess
damn it
still many hours still done yeah that
don't look normal
let's get a closer look
okay someone said that this there's like
okay someone i've been actually talking
with other people that are playing again
but i haven't had the ending spoiled for
me just yet
but someone told me that there's like
multiple monsters or there's a killer
and a monster or there's multiple things
that are actually killing all these
people
a la cabin in the woods style oh
i should probably be stealthy about this
shouldn't i
oh those aren't good sounds are those
poachies
all those poochy wooches do the poochy
wushies want to come say hi to me
i'll say hi to you poochie wuches as
long as you don't do nothing to me
i won't have any reason to do anything
to you
yes a i'm a doggy look at me wandering
up the stairs like a doggy woggie
no one bother me i'm barging in the
front door apparently
at leisurely stroll
anybody oh yeah it's hauntingly
beautiful
you're gorgeous okay wait what is that
over there there's something over here
first
hello let me guess bad things happened
here
good in the creepiest place on planet
earth
aren't you still not worried about what
happened to jess back there why are you
still sulking
all right i'm not even gonna try the
front door just in case it's like gonna
cause a noise and cause me to die
horribly
might as well go over here where it's
probably telling me to go
yeah and someone said that the monster
is in relation to a monster called the
wendigo
or something like that yep oh
yeah hope my fingers don't break yep
couldn't have been a little more noisy
good it's dark
don't break your feet ow your feet this
guy's bones are made out of rubber
that's why i was able to pick up that
wood oh so gently
all right anything down here that i need
any secret goodies that i'm not gonna
overlook
oh hello oh what was that
was that a ratty roo
hello what
why am i doing this i didn't recall
coming up with this idea
okay that was good enough i'm glad i
moved that over there oh i see what i
needed
i have no idea that i was even up there
why would i have
why would i be wandering around any of
this alone
because at this point why am i going
into this place by myself why wouldn't i
try to go back down the mountain reunite
with my friends
probably because this is a cliched
horror adventure
with some other ulterior mysteries going
on
and everyone has to split up because
that's the only way to progress through
these games
something's gonna happen something's
gonna happen i know this game and it's
jump scary ways
okay there was another there was another
glowy glue over there but i don't know
if it was important because it came over
here well i guess i'm never going to
find out because i'm not going to be
able to go back to it if it was really
important
game breakingly important i'm going to
be pissed off
clever thanks for the color commentary
buddy
i think he's just royally pissed off
that he got cock-blocked by a monster
cause he's just that kind of bro don't
worry
i was voted prom king no one wants to
mess with me
i thought yeah i thought i saw glowy
okay i'm not even moving right now
good doggie good doggy good doggy wongie
wu
hello that better not be jesus bone
yeah maybe it's time to give up and go
back
just maybe no apparently it's time to
play oh yeah
let's go right for the i do i wouldn't i
really wouldn't have done that
because dogs are kind of smart dogs kind
of know and noises are
not normally supposed to be noises so
that's gonna i'm gonna be stupid
elsewhere i'm gonna be a big dumb dummy
dude over here
huh broken rocks maybe i should punch
him with my face
maybe i should go break my hands on more
logs
here maybe i should go look at this
shiny thing over here that's the only
thing that attracts my attention
oh yeah is my girlfriend dead man will
yeah men sana incorporisano
okay cool 1922. i wonder if that's gonna
be any sort of important for me
but i guess i might be too stupid to
remember numbers like that
man
[Applause]
all right continuing forward
oh man why is there a morgan a
sanatorium actually the old-style
sanatorium i believe was more of a
hospital than an actual insane asylum
actually was it ever considered the same
song maybe like a combo deal i have no
idea
hello yes please
hmm yes nope just faked out come on
turn i'm not even doing this come on oh
yeah there we go
huh hmm if i could read
words i might be interested in this okay
so some sort of assault the mining
company
unfortunate full internal inquiry has
been released launched
okay all right cool that's helpful for
something i suppose
is there anything else that's actually
gonna help me like save my girl
save the rest of the people survive this
no i'm just gonna travel around in the
winter
with a wife no that ain't good
okay i mean i couldn't possibly be
cold or anything like that did the music
pick up and all those doggies coming my
way
that sounds like it
[Music]
i'm just not even gonna go any sort of
faster
all right come on yep
interesting 12 miners after the collapse
of the mine and subsequent rescue
delicate nature of the patience we've
closed off a wing of the sanatorium
psychological
value okay the men with respiratory
problems of underground bronchoscopy and
prescribed a treatment of
streptomyomycin
the other simply kept under strict
24-hour observation
okay so what does that all have to do
with something about this so there's
something to do
with the mine collapse and either
why the mine collapsed or like what
effect that had on what happened on this
mountain
if it is all related because it might
actually not be related at all who knows
i certainly don't oh don't worry doggy
i'm coming to throw myself
into your jaws any minute now
oh good is this impending death i was
wondering when i was gonna get to this
good thing i spent that last bullet when
i didn't need it if i just didn't shoot
the guy would i have been
oh hi nice move okay
that looks like a knife i want some of
that
me him yeah me i'm like that no take it
anyway
okay maybe i shouldn't morally i kind of
object to things like that but
maybe i need to i don't know revenge
okay cool i got it now i can defend
myself question
mark when did i get a
where did i put that when did i get that
i just happen to be wearing jeans that
have a sheath holder in it okay
right so where am i headed now
can i be a little bit quicker about this
that was something that uh ryan from
zindagh pointed out to me it's really
funny because
in the inner cuts of the okay
there appears to be a doggy in my midst
do i need to hide from that or do i
charge blindly forward
i'm going to charge blindly forward
bring it on
that's clever placement so doggy
literally just walked by here and i'm
not going to worry about it at all
great great
uh oh
little little strange a little strange
little strange it's gonna
be weird and close here looking down
okay moving along
that's that's a little bizarre i gotta
admit
no idea why oh oh yeah
oh yeah touch it oh yeah touch it oh
definitely touch it
oh no oh oh i what almost gotcha
almost gotcha oh
no you come back let's camp
oh man i almost got that one i will get
ya
well this is a bad idea
yeah you're gonna have to do it come on
come on you were a big enough duke to go
in there
what of course amputate the fingers you
got to get out of there bro
you gotta oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] come on you
big pansy
hey i got good luck from that owie owie
that stinky wonky
yeah oh yeah
50-year-old medical equipment not gonna
be all that bad for me
okay cool uh shake it off bruh whatever
man i bet if i would have done that or
tried to pry open it it would have just
like
oh catch a tiger by the toe
the [ __ ] are you on about mate i want
the [ __ ] to go
okay oh yeah
you're fine just shake it off so
apparently that was a good choice
because i bet if i would have tried to
open it would have been uh well probably
would have broken the machete and then i
wouldn't had a machete
this place just gets better and better
hello
strange skull more like strange face
okay
why am i still so calm i just lost two
fingers
god damn i am a
like badass i do okay why wouldn't i
have
done done that before hello anything
gonna pop out of me
i have a feeling the answer is yes hurp
anything going to chop these fingers off
yeah stick your face right in there
buddy yeah pull it out for some reason
this one's really intriguing
hey look it's a thing oh boy
i don't know what this means but i could
guess
attack by inmate fatal ass that was the
door opening that was the door opening
come on come on
hello who's uh
who's a who's a thumpy wumpus
huh you thumping in here i don't
appreciate no thumpy whump or wooz
sure i'm glad all these bodies just
evaporated into vapor that's totally
good for me to breathe
in and get all my dirty chopped off
fingers on registration of deaths
body was not discovered until 68 hours
after death sections of intestinal
kidney were apparently eaten by the
attacker
great cool glad that happened is that
gonna happen to me
i bet the answer's yes all right come on
you
come out hey ho what you gonna do
is anything gonna kill me now probably
yeah that's [ __ ] sick
hello unfazed just a badass oh yeah go
right for it
totally cool totally cool totally cool
okay let's check this out yep this was
worth it
this was worth all this pain and
suffering
hello hi can i get through please i've
been through a lot today
i didn't get laid and then i lost some
fingers so yeah
thanks bro thanks
yeah take that best okay bye
hello one new nightmare awaits me now
what living hell shall i wander into now
seriously why did i not go back down the
mountain
i might have been afraid of freezing to
death i suppose it's always an option
probably better than what's gonna happen
to me in here oh no i almost look a
little scared
oh god am i doing this really i'm doing
this now okay
come on come on come on
no quick time no quick quick
okay all righty then
right what was that
okay okay none of this is
okay i'm just glad i didn't have to do a
quick time event for any of that
wait was i supposed to look out that
window or i thought that might have been
an option to jump out now
psycho crap ew nice quip there buddy
all your friends are dying and so are
you i want you to get to the
business
all right come on now
oh this looks good oh i'm glad i'll just
grab onto it with my finger
oh wait ow my knees
right yeah yeah
good good job you came full circle you
accomplished nothing
except now i guess you do have a key
card i mean this guy seems in really
really good spirits for being in his bad
shape as he is so you know like
maybe he should be that's a
smidge more panicked just a heady bit
anymore
all right whatever all right carrying on
oh [ __ ] you whoa why what what do i ah
wait [ __ ] [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ] oh
oh oh
okay okay i was supposed to do that
oh okay how was i supposed to know that
man god damn are you kidding me that was
sheer luck
whose sheer stupidity i have no idea
what i was supposed to be doing
okay all righty then
this is this is great this is great
great great great hello
what have we here ah it's some kind of
clothing
weird it's a death jacket
it's going to die me to death oh look a
gurn come on give me the gurn
ah something in my eye her
oh what oh let me ah
me i'm funky thunk good all right
give me that i like it i like it a lot
so now what we're gonna be able to shoot
something what happened to that dog
i don't have a bone to feed it so i
don't know if he's gonna be ah there's
something in my eye
okay continuing forward
hello the stokey stash exposed
of course yes i'll take that why not
oh yeah that's right there was a clue in
the mountain the minor thing there was a
guy
smoking on some stogies so i'm under the
assumption
that this might just be the same guy but
it doesn't explain how the girl
was dragged out of the freaking window
yup
oh wait okay here we go
hello oh something for the poochie keep
the wolves fat and happy
oh i'd love it i hope it's human i bet
it is
all right poochie come over here yo
poojie who won't you little bony won't
you
hold your daddy whatever you want a
little bony i sure i'm glad i didn't try
to punch you
because that would have been horrible
because sometimes the best decision is
to do nothing
but you'll never know which one is the
one that's not supposed to be the do
because it's not obvious hey bobby
you want a bony money
yeah yeah i can't see anything but you
want a buddy
yay
good popper snappers good
i could afford to lose a few more
fingers
that's right yay it's a
bond oh boy okay so with that one
i guess i did good by sheer luck
i've done good i lost some funniness
but i got a lot more brave and
my relationship with jess has decreased
i can't imagine why
oh well so thank you everybody so much
for watching check out the uh other
videos that i've done in the past other
series that i played in the past
let me know what you think of this game
in the comments down below thank you
everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video bye-bye
we didn't want to hurt anybody yeah
we're like looking through and all of a
sudden we turn into the lingerie
department
which is the whole store
[Music]
good